[Music]
it was a swift and bold move in response
to a complex Middle East crisis which
has dragged on for six long years a
barrage of American cruise missiles
directed at a Syrian Air Base after an
alleged chemical attack by Syria's
president against his own people just
two days earlier
tonight I ordered a targeted military
strike on the airfield in Syria from
where the chemical attack was launched
it is in this vital national security
interest of the United States to prevent
and deter the spread and use of deadly
chemical weapons syrian state television
run pictures of what it said was the
missile strike it has denied carrying
out a chemical attack suggesting it
could have hit a rebel stockpile of
chemicals during an air strike Syria has
condemned what it says are its efforts
to thwart terrorism in its own country
this condemnable u.s. aggression
confirms the continuation of the flawed
u.s. strategy and undermines the process
of combating terrorism that the Syrian
military is undertaking 59 Tomahawk
cruise missiles were fired from two US
warships in the eastern Mediterranean
towards the sharat airbase in homs
province which is around a hundred
kilometers from concha Kune the scene of
the alleged attack President Trump says
the sharat airbase was used to launch
the chemical attack against Syrian
civilians this is what prompted him to
act more than 80 people were killed and
many many more battled poisonous
chemicals probably sarin gas unleashed
on their town Britain says it doesn't
think this is the start of an extensive
campaign against the Syrian regime we
fully supported and the Americans
believe that this action is limited
it's very narrowly focused against the
airfield the aircraft and the equipment
that the Americans believe were used in
the gas attack and they have exhausted
all other means whether by coincidence
all designed president Trump's missile
strike happened when the leader of the
world's other superpower China arrived
in America for their fur
meeting the strike leaves Donald Trump
looking at the very least decisive in
front of Xi Jinping who has the power to
influence another nation threatening
global stability North Korea the world
is starting to see what kind of foreign
policy Donald Trump intends to pursue
Lisa Holland Sky News